hello rejects its Greg its yeah we're
gonna watch the horse trailer or the
trailer for the heart of the movie yet
okay if you've ever had a pet you know
there are the most terrifying things in
the world yeah
they're scary they're vicious they turn
on you haven't had a single pet I
haven't had to kill my own bare hands
so the movie is written by one of the co
riders a fantastic four fend for snicker
over there is called and he also was one
of the writers of The Exorcist show I
want to see this trailer i Mitchell sent
it our way
they said you got to check it out G
Reger E it's rated R for strong bloody
violence some grisly images language and
brief sexuality Oh
much like my life actuality hey remember
me I was just wondering if you want
again maybe inner [ __ ] you man love
seafood
Wow place on the ocean well sure yeah
holy garlic Orion does helps them back
I'm serious though halt move on already
popular
who's the guy already so he'd have a
boyfriend
like it's lightning bolt was there the
lightning bolt be love takes work
are you really gonna let turn me on when
you're keeping a girl in a cake
jeez that was one of those really
effective trailers where when they show
you like what the AH what the critics
have been saying you're like sounds cool
got to see that because yeah I was like
starting to think right when she got
caged those thing like this is kind of a
typical serial killer a kind of
psychopathic thriller but then when she
starts responding the way she does
you're like oh man what a cool little
clever way to flip that because yeah
very good trailers great yeah because
that whole time who's that actress
that's why we have him give up here and
seniya solo on solos daughter Sagna solo
I love the setup of it like okay you got
a creepy kind of guy you know like a
little Elijah Wood for maniac yeah the
hair like that kind of mania and I was
thinking like Dominic Monaghan does his
name right
what Hobbit was it Pippin Frodo Sam he
was either merry or pivot I think he's
married no tippin's the other one dude
he's the one who goes Pippin gets mad at
Pittman Pippin yeah merry trust me you
want to be proven wrong hey Doc
brandybuck merry all right hopefully we
never get that he's creepy he has the
other interesting accent he's yeah he
sees a lot creepier with an American
accent like he's suave you feel like he
can easily be swab with his natural
accent but when he's connected it's very
yeah for him to look like a creepy guy
but I love that flip because I'm like
whoa is she it's like you're watching
two bad people unfold
yeah and two and and and they're still
so you don't get a sense of
love story at all here but there but one
critic said like a dip a weird kind of
love story and then the tagline at the
end of it was pet a love story yeah
twisted in some like I'm really really
really intrigued to see this yeah are
you intrigued to see this movie I am too
these love a twisted kind of [ __ ] that
love story
yeah maybe and these are these movies
are always exciting in a sense this
isn't like the kind of movie that comes
out constantly however when it does I'm
always intrigued and they're always
these movies are tricky
to me and that's part of the fun
watching them set their thing up and
seeing how they see where it goes and
how they nail it cuz yeah it's hard to
make a movie like this work I feel like
there's some that kind of fall apart at
the end and that's part of the fun of
the ride to me is like seeing how
tightly they can pull everything
together and at least in terms of what
we see in this trailer like the
performance ISM even when a trailer can
give you twists like that's that excites
me yeah yeah totally
oh totally like this trailer gives me a
lot of twists and not a lot of answer so
like I am totally intrigued the first
toys with that uh you know perception of
someone who Facebook stalks you looks up
your entire profile bases off that and
because it's easy to do that it's it's
so easy to do that how do you think I
pick up any girl or a guy I date I've
dated plenty of guys Grindr yeah no
really long term yeah cause like when
solo started like banging her head
against that cage that looks so painful
then you get like these different images
or like you see Dominic Monaghan
he's even like crying in a corner and
stuff yeah something tells me that she's
probably gonna like somehow fall for him
she's gonna stay kind of ate well and
she's gonna flip the table on him yeah
you know like that that cage is sinister
but at least again in terms of what
we've seen here like it seems like she's
got a few tricks up her sleeves in some
funny way interesting psychological
thriller it seems like it's gonna be one
of those thrillers that is a contained
environment like it's primarily gonna be
at this guy's wherever he lives in that
basement yeah you don't really see her
out of the cage when she's in the cage a
lot of the images they show
you don't really see her out of the cage
so I'm interested to see what the how
the skirt really plays everything out
with the writings like and how much
ingenuity there is there it's always
really cool when somebody takes kind of
a one setting you know isolated setting
and puts a twisty sort of story around
it now I just want to see if they could
pull it off and it at least from all
these blurbs it sounds like they do and
it looks like you got two different kind
of bad guys here I feel like you got the
Dominic Monaghan character who kind of
doesn't view himself at all like he's a
bad person he seems like he has that
kind of innocent personality he even
says I'm doing this for you something
tells me that solo watching her
performance in this trailer kind of
seems like the she is aware of the evil
and her and she's letting that I don't
know I just you kind of get what I'm
gonna hear when you do maybe I question
my whole life me no no I I don't it's
possible I don't know like you know it's
just a trailer so I don't know exactly
there's still a good amount of mystery
to me is like I'm sure there's some
crazy locked up in there but I don't
know how much of that is brought on by
the desperateness of the situation
versus like is she crazy now in that
diner or is this just the tipping point
you know I feel like she might have
cracked when she finally got put in that
cage yeah what do you mean what do you
mean like she might have already had
some kind of crazy past before that
diner
well yeah is that what you're getting at
yeah yeah it's like I that's what the
movie is here to tell us I'm really
excited
yeah really I'm really looking forward
to it because the trailer doesn't reveal
much I like I love a horror movie where
it's like the set up seems typical but
no it's not one and those like twisted
you know isolation movies ya know we're
putting somebody in a cage does not mean
that you have control in this situation
I always like those those reversals so
when does this come out when can we see
this December 2nd dude Christmas time
Christmas perfect movie for Christmas
dude I'm gonna take my family to watch
this movie yeah all together take my
little niece and nephews to go watch
this movie yeah let's find a school and
treat them to a field trip show them
what having a real pet is like yeah you
know everybody should have a pet I feel
like you know my nephews they need to
know how they should treat women when
the role
this is a great example or maybe it'll
be a really good cautionary tale if
you're thinking about putting a woman
into a giant cage beneath your home
maybe you should not do that I got to
tell you ninety-nine percent of time it
doesn't work but every time you know you
stay persistent that 1%
lucky you might get up all right rejects
review the child subscribe today become
a reject John is reasons to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram he's also the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue mouse and the real rejects
all true you guys you take care of your
mail pets count it it's all there